[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ल तो सबसे पहले
तो वेलकम टू डे 13 ऑफ दिस बेस्ट मास्टरी
कोर्स तो आप लोग सबसे पहले मुझे एक चीज
बता दीजिए कि सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही
है नहीं दे रही उसके बाद फदर हम अपने
क्लास को कंटिन्यू करते हैं एंड सॉरी फॉर
दैट कि अबकी बार क्लास लेट हुई मुझे टाइम
नहीं मिला मैं कहीं बिजी था तो इसी रीजन
से मैं आपके क्लास शेड्यूल नहीं कर पाया
तीन दिन का गैप हो गया आई एम सॉरी फॉर
दैट सो प्लीज एक बार चैट में कंफर्म कर
दीजिए सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है या नहीं आ
रही
थैंक यू थैंक यू तो लास्ट क्लास में हमने
जो पढ़ा था वो पोजीशन पैरामीटर के बारे
में पढ़ा था वो भी इंपोर्टेंट था और उसके
बाद हमने पढ़ा था स्पेशल पैरामीटर के बारे
में
स्पेशल पैरामीटर में भी हमने क्या किया था
कि दो पैरामीटर्स के बारे में पढ़ा था एक
डॉलर हैज और एक डॉलर जीरो के बारे में
डॉलर हैज क्या करता था कि वो आपको
काउंटिंग प्रोवाइड करता था कि कितने
स्पेशल पोजीशन पैरामीटर यूज किए गए हैं
आपके स्क्रिप्ट के साथ या आपके कमांड के
साथ उसकी काउंटिंग आपको एक
साथ काउंट करके दे देता था नेक्स्ट जो आप
यूज यूज किया डॉलर जीरो क्या करता था कि
वो आपका उसको जहां पर यूज करते हो उसी
हिसाब से उसको काम करता अगर आपने सेल में
यूज कि तो सेल का नाम आपके सामने शो कर
देता था अगर स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर यूज कि तो
स्क्रिप्ट का फाइल नेम आपको शो कर देता था
और दोनों को अगर हम कंबाइंडली यूज करें तो
हमने यूज करके भी दिखाया था तो वो काफी
अच्छा खासा कॉमिनेशन के साथ आपका क्या
काफी हेल्पफुल करता है आपके स्क्रिप्ट को
अच्छी बनाने में बेहतर बनाने में कंडीशन
बेस बनाने में और खास कर के वहां पर जहां
पर आपको एरर क्रिएट होने पर अगर हेल्प
फाइल क्रिएट करके देनी हो तो इन दोनों
कॉमिनेशन काफी आपकी हेल्प कर रहा था तो हम
अब बढ़ते हैं हम नेक्स्ट जो स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स है उसके बारे में पढ़ते हैं तो
मैं अभी अपने सीट पर चलता हूं अभी आपके
पास ये
के ये रहा चलो हम चलते हैं अपनी सीट के
ऊपर तो अभी हम बात करने वाले हैं
ओके
धर नेक्स्ट जो नेक्स्ट आपका जो क्या है
क्या बोलते हैं
कि नेक्स्ट आपका जो स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स
रहेगा कंटिन्यू करते हैं हम
स्पेशल स्पेशल
पैरा मीटर स्पेशल पैरामीटर य रहा जो
नेक्स्ट स्पेशल पैरामीटर है वो आपका है
डॉलर रेट डॉलर रेट अब ये क्या करर इसके
बारे में आपको मैं बताता हूं डलर रेट करता
क्या
है ये क्या करता है
इट ये क्या करता है
आपका
इट
अलाउ इट
अलाउ इट अलाउ इट
अलाउ अस टू इट अलाउ अस टू
एक्सेस
ऑल
द पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर ल द पोजीशन पैरामीटर एट वनस एट
वनस ट
ए पास टू अवर स्क्रिप्ट पावर स्क्रिप्ट
एंड इट
सेपरेट इट सेपरेट्स
ई पैरामीटर
पैरामीटर विद ए स्पेस स्पेस अब देखो इसका
मतलब क्या है लास्ट क्लास में जो मैंने
आपको एक एग्जांपल के साथ एक जो असाइनमेंट
था छोटा सा उसके साथ आपको एक चीज करके
दिखाई थी असाइनमेंट के साथ को पोजीशन
पैरामीटर का यूज करते हुए जहां पर हम क्या
कर रहे थे सब्सट्रैक्शन और एडिशन कर रहे
थे वहां पर क्या करना पड़ता था पोजीशन
पैरामीटर की जब वैल्यू को हमें क्या करना
पड़ रहा था फैच करना पड़ रहा था उसको
वैल्यू को हमें यूज करना पड़ रहा था तो
हमें क्या करना पड़ था बार बारबार वन बाय
वन हम क्या कर रहे थे उसको उसकी वैल्यू को
रेफर कर रहे थे उसको यूज कर रहे थे कि
डॉलर डॉलर वन डॉलर टू डॉलर थ ऐसे अप टू
डलर 11 ड 12 ऐसे हम यूज कर रहे थे बट अब
डॉलर एट द रेट आपका क्या शो करता है जो
डॉलर ट रेट है ये ये
आपको हेल्प करता है किस बारे में कि जो
आपकी जो मेहनत थी वन बाय वन आपको जो
वैल्यू यूज करनी पड़ती थी पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स की उसको इजी कर रहा ये क्या
करता था कि आप जब भी डॉलर द रेट यूज करोगे
सारे के सारे पोशन पैरामीटर का वैल्यू को
एक बार एक्सेस कर लेगा एक बार में एक्सेस
कर देगा जो भी आपके स्क्रिप्ट को पास किया
उसके बाद उनको क्या कर देया फरदर सेपरेट
कर देगा स्पेस के साथ उनको सेपरेट कर देगा
हर एक वर्ड के अंदर फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने
अगर डॉलर ट द रेट के तो कैसे ये सेपरेट
करेगा उसको लिखेगा डॉलर वन डॉलर वन अ डॉलर
टू स्पेस सेपरेटेड डर 3 ऐसे अप
टू ये n एक रिप्रेजेंटेशन ले टू ए तक ए
क्या एक रिप्रेजेंटेशन ले रहा हूं ए क्या
रिपें कितने भी हो सकता है अब य क्या करता
है अब एक और लाइन लिख देता हूं
ई
ईच ऑफ ईच
ऑफ
दज च ऑफ
दज
पोजीशनल पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर्स
इ कंसीडर्ड इ कंसीडर्ड एज इट्स ऑन वर्ड्स
इटस
न
ओन इट्स ओन वर्ड मतलब ह न वर्ड ल ओ आरडी
ओके नव क्या करता है कि जो ह पोज पटर उसको
एक अलग वर्ड कंसीडर किया जाता है जिससे
क्या
होगा जो जिससे क्या है
ल
सब्जेक्ट
टू वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
और सभी सभी जैसे क्या वो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
के लिए सब्जेक्ट वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
इंडिविजुअली इन डी आई वी आई डी यू ए
इंडिविजुअली ओके इंडिविजुअली ऑल सब्जेक्ट
टू व स्प्लिटिंग इंडिविजुअली इससे क्या
होगा कि जब आपने रेट को यूज किया तो हर एक
को क्या करता है एक बार में एक्सेस कर
लेगा उसका स्पेस सेपरेट को रख देगा हर एक
को क्या है एक वर्ड कंसीडर किया जाएगा हर
एक वर्ड क्या है इंडिविजुअल व स्लिटिंग व
स्प्लिटिंग के अंदर आएगा इ क्या आगा व
स्लिटिंग के अंदर आएगा फॉर एपल इसका भी
एग्जांपल आपको शो करूंगा हम यूज करेंगे
दूसरा आपका स्पेशल पैरामीटर होता है जिसको
हम बात करते हैं कि अगर मैं डबल कोट के
अंदर इसको रप कर दू डॉलर एट रेट को डलर एट
रेट को तो आपको क्या लगता कि आपका आउटपुट
क्या आना चाहिए आपको क्या लगता है कि आपका
जो आउटपुट आएगा वो क्या आना चाहिए आप
बोलोगे सर मेरा जो आउटपुट है वो ऐसे आना
चाहिए आप बोलोगे कि जो आप बोलोगे कि हां
सर डबल कोट के अंदर यह आएगा डॉलर वन स्पेस
सेपरेटेड डलर ट स्पेस सेपरेटेड डलर 3
स्पेस अप
टू डॉलर ए ये आएगा सर आपका हमारा आउटपुट
नो इसका मतलब यह नहीं आएगा
नो
ट्स नॉट द ट्रू ये ट्रू नहीं है एक्चुअल
में जो आपका आउटपुट आएगा वो क्या आएगा
आपका वो आपका आउटपुट आएगा इधर ये कैसे
इसको फेस करेगा कि डबल कोट उसके बाद डॉलर
वन ऐसे फेस स्पेस सेपरेटेड डबल कोट डॉलर
टू फेस स्पेस सेपरेटेड डबल कोट डलर 3 डॉलर
थ देन स्पेस सेपरेटेड ये अप टू रहेगा
आपका डॉलर ए ये एक रिप्रेजेंटेशन आपको पता
है ये इस तरीके से आपका रिप्रेजेंट करेगा
ना कि इसकी तरीके से ये आपका ये
रिप्रेजेंटेशन नहीं रहे जबक आपका
रिप्रेजेंटेशन क्या आएगा ये आएगा
इंडिविजुअली हर एक को क्या करता है
इंडिविजुअली कोट करके सेपरेट कर देगा
इंडिज क्योंकि हर एक अपने आप में एक वर्ड
है हर एक को क्या करता है ये इंडिविजुअली
उसको डबल कोट के अंदर रप करके आपके सामने
रिप्रेजेंट करेगा कि अभ आपको पता चल गया
अब य इंडिविजुअली इसने रप कर दिया इसका
मतलब क्या है य पर वर्ड स्लिटिंग भी काम
नहीं करेगी वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग भी काम नहीं
करेगी तो य पर आएगा कि
ई ईच
ऑफ
दोज डि
विजुअल डी यू ए डी ए इंडिविजुअल अरे या
स्पेलो मिस्टेक आजकल बहुत हो रही है बहुत
ही ज्यादा सॉरी फॉर ट
इंडिविजुअल
वर्ड्स रप इन डबल
कोट्स डबल कोट्स
उसको डबल कोट्स के अंदर रैप कर देगा रप इन
डबल कोट्स उसके बाद क्या होगा डबल कोट्स
एंड
नो एंड
विल नो लोंगर विल नो
लोंगर
अंडरगो अंडरगो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
वर्ड्स स्लिटिंग वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग अब इसके
अंदर क्या है वर्ड स्लिटिंग इसकी परफॉर्म
नहीं होगी यहां पर यहां पर वर्स स्लेटिंग
परफॉर्म नहीं होगी फॉर एग्जांपल अभी मैं
आपको शो करता हूं प्रैक्टिकली शो करता
आपके सामने बिल्कुल सारी की सारी चीज
प्रैक्टिकली शो करूंगा तो एक बार और समझ
लीजिए सबको मैं प्रैक्टिकली दिखाऊंगा ठीक
है नेक्स्ट जो आपका है जो स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स है आपका नेक्स्ट स्पेशल
पैरामीटर आता है एक डॉलर और एस्टिक्स
जिसको हम बोलते हैं जिसको स्टार बोलते हो
आप लोग ये बिल्कुल सेम काम करता है सेम एज
इट इज इट सेम एट इ एट इज किसका किसकी तरह
जो डॉलर है एट रेट बिल्कुल उसकी तरह काम
करर कोई डिफरेंस नहीं है बिल्कुल सारा
आउटपुट सेम करर कोई भी डिफरेंस नहीं है
बिल्कुल जैसे उसम काम कर बिल्कुल उसका प
काम करता है नेक्स्ट बिल्कुल देखो जो आपका
डबल अगर मैं इसी को डबल कोट के अंदर करता
हूं डॉलर और स्टार अगर मैं इसके अंदर डबल
कोट कर देता हूं तो अब आप लोग क्या करता
है कि इसका क्या टपुट आएगा इसका जो आउटपुट
आपको लगता है क्या आएगा इसका आउटपुट क्या
आना चाहिए आप जो लगेगा देखो क्या करता है
यह
कि देखो यह क्या करता है
लिखो इंस्टेड ऑफ इंस्टेड ऑफ प्लेसिंग
इंस्टेड ऑफ प्लेसिंग ए स्पेस इंस्ट
प्लेसिंग स्पेस बिटवीन
पोजीशन पोजीशनल पैरामीटर
पैरामीटर लाइक
डॉलर एट द
रेट डक डज यह क्या करता है उसकी बजाय क्या
करता
है
इट विल
प्लेस
द फर्स्ट
कैरेक्टर फर्स्ट कैरेक्टर ऑफ द
आईएफस वेरिएबल वेरिएबल
आईस
वेरिएबल फर्स्ट कक्टर गा उसको इनके बीच
में क्या कर आ फर्स्ट वेरिएबल
बिटवीन बिटवीन
इच पोजीशनल
पोजीशन
पैरामीटर पोजीशनल
पैरामीटर पोशन पैरामीटर ओके तो जो
डॉलर क्या कर दिया है जबक जो आपने डॉलर
रेट के केस में क्या हुपे सेपरेटेड कर
दिया था और उनको डबल कोट के अंदर ड कर
दिया था अब ये क्या करे य भी डबल कोट के
अंदर उनको रप करेगा बट क्या है जो आस
वेरिएबल का जो सबसे पहली वैल्यू उसके
हिसाब से उसको डट के अंदर में फर एपल
मैंने लिया एपल फ एपल मैं ले रहा हूं
फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने लिया आपके सामने जो
एग्जांपल लिया वो है कि जो आईएफएस वेरिएबल
की जो वैल्यू मैंने रखी इक्वल टू वो रखी
मैंने कॉमा ये रखी मैंने कॉमा तो जो
वैल्यू जो आपकी वैल्यू पे सेपरे आएगी जो
वैल्यू रहेगी वो रहेगी आपकी डबल कोट उसके
बाद डॉलर वन उसके बाद कॉमा उसके
बाद ओके सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी ये डबल कोट नहीं
रहेगा इसमें इसमें डबल कोट नहीं रहेगा
इसमें डबल कोट नहीं रहेगा ये क्या करेगा
डॉलर वन उसके बाद कॉमा डॉलर टू कमा डॉलर थ
कमा डॉलर फ उसके बाद एज इट इज कमा के साथ
ही जाएगा ये अप टू डॉलर ए अप टू डॉलर ए
यहां तक इसके आप आपका आउटपुट शो होगा अब
मैं आपको प्रैक्टिकली शो करता हूं कि आप
टर्मिनल में ले जाकर कैसे काम करेंगे सारी
चीज तो आपको समझ में आएगा कि डॉलर
रेट कैसे काम कर स्पेशल पैरामीटर इसका
मतलब क्या ये सारे क्या प्रैक्टिकली आपको
यूज करने को मिलेंगे अपने पास से कुछ भी
नहीं बता रहा प्रैक्टिकली सारी यूज करने
को आपको मिलेंगे ये ये रहा डरेट एक ये
रहा ये नेक्स्ट य बिल्कुल सेम इट इज है यह
बिल्कुल सेम है इसमें कुछ भी डिफरेंस नहीं
है यह सारे स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स के पार्ट है
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स के पार्ट है ओके यह रहा
अब ऐसे भी आज हम कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
पढ़ने वाले हैं टाइम पास नहीं करने वाले
खास कर के जो काफी इंपोर्टेंट आने वाली है
तो यह देखो अभी सारा वैसे इंपोर्टेंट ही
चल रहा है आपका हम चलते हम टर्मिनल पर अब
टर्मिनल पर चलते हैं तो मैं आपको सबसे
पहले शो करता हूं कि एक कमांड की हेल्प से
कि ये रहा मैं एक स्क्रिप्ट बनाता हूं ननो
उसके बाद ये स्पेशल पैरामीटर स्क्रिप ड
एसस ये रही इसको मैं ओपन करता हूं अभी
इसके अंदर
मैं सि बंग लाइन ऐड करता हूं सि बंग लाइन
आपको पता है क्या होती है बिन और बैस किया
मैंने देन उसके बाद एक पास बिन और बैस
किया मैंने देन उसके बाद स्पेस दिया अब
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं एक बार मैंने क्या
किया कि मैंने कि एक और डॉलर ट रेट कर
दिया मैंने एक डॉलर रेट कर दिया और इसको
कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स कर दिया देन मैं
इसको क्या सीच मोड परमिशन है मेरे पास ओ
परमिशन आपको देखने को मिल र होगी य
पर स्पेशल य
रहा ओके री स्पेशल
स्पेशल स्पेशल य ओके चलो मैं स्पेशल को कर
देता हूं क्लियर कर देता हूं इसको परमिशन
देनी होगी मुझे परमिशन देता हूं तो सीच
मोड
744 देन स्पेशल मैं इसको परमिशन दे दिया
अब मैं क्या करता हूं इसको मैं रन करता
हूं
स्पेशल एव थ 4 5 6 से दे दिया मैंने ये
सारी वैल्यू मैंने पास कर दी उसके बाद
मैंने क्या कर दिया हिट एंटर अभी देखो
इसने आउटपुट में जो शो किया एक साथ ही कर
दिया स्पेस सेपरेटेड टूथ 4 5 6 से स्पेस
सेटेड आपके सामने शो कर ना अगर मुझे इनकी
वैल्यू को अगर मुझे यूज करना होता अपने
उसके अंदर स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर तो मैं क्या
करता था वैसे इंडिविजुअली क्या करता था
अगर मैं ओपन करूं ये
रहा ये रहा अबी देखो अभी इसी में का अदर
वाइज मैं क्या लिखता था एकको क्या करता था
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं एकको अ डॉलर वन डॉलर
टू डलर 3 डलर फ डलर फ डॉलर
हुआ डॉलर फो ऐसे करता थान वैल्यू को फच
करने के लिए कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स इसको
यूज करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट को यह देखो पहले
ऐसे करता था लेकिन अब इसने हमारा काम
स्पेस वैल्यू को शो कर दिया लेकिन य पर
क्या कुछ प्रॉब्लम रहे जैसे कि फर एपल
मैंने क्या किया अगर मैं फाइल क्रिएट कर
रहा हूं अगर मैं स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर फाइल
क्रिएट कर रहा हूं जैसे कि मैंने क्या
किया यह रहान करके अंदर जाते हैं अभी मैं
क्या करता हूं इसको डिलीट कर देता हूं
इसको पूरा डिलीट कर देता हूं ट य रहा अब
बस ओके देन मैंने य पर क्या किया टच किया
टच और मैं क्या करता हूं डॉलर रेट मैंने
मेंशन किया डलर मेंशन किया कंट्रोल एस
कंट्रोल एक्स देन मैं क्या कर रहा ह य थ 4
5 6 से ये फाइल में क्रिएट कर रहा हूं तो
मैंने ये फाइल कट की ट एंटर कर दिया मैं
काम कर रहा हूं फो तक लेता हूं ट एंटर कर
दिया अब मैं एलस करके दिखा आपके सामने तो
टूथ 4 5 स 4 5 स कौन से आया अ आई थिंक ये
इससे पहले से कुछ था इसमें अगर मैं काम कर
देता हूं आरम कर देता हूं 1 2 3 4 5
ओके अ
वन 2 3 4 5 6स ये रिमूव कर दिया अब एलस कर
दि तो ये इधर नहीं है अब मैं क्या
स्क्रिप्ट को रन करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट को
जैसे ही मैंने रन किया ये रहा अभी एलस
करके दिखाता हूं यह रहा 1 2 3 4 इसने फाइल
क्रिएट कर दी अगर मैं क्या करता स्पेशल दो
पैरामीटर की वैल्यू में अगर मैंने क्या कर
देता अगर मुझे ऐसा लिखा होता मैंने डबल
कोट डबल कोट के अंदर मैं लिख
देता डेली उसके बाद फीडबैक डेली फीडबैक
लिख देता देन उसके बाद स्पेस दिया मैंने
और मैं क्या लिख देता हूं एन टी एच एल वाई
मंथली मंथली रिपोर्ट्स रिपोर्ट्स मंथली
रिपोर्ट्स और मैं इसको भी डबल कोट के अंदर
मेंशन कर देता इसको भी मैं क्या कर देता
डबल कोट के अंदर मेंशन कर देता बट हिट
एंटर करता अभी आपको क्या लगता है क्या
आंसर आया होगा अभी इसने क्या कर दिया
देखो इधर यह रहा मंथली रिपोर्ट्स
और द फीडबैक
फीडबैक मंथली रिपोर्ट्स और डेली फीडबैक ये
रहा डेली फीडबैक अभी सब कु इसने अलग-अलग
कर दिया है क्योंकि यहां पर वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग काम किया है क्योंकि यहां पर
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग काम किया है अब मुझे क्या
करना है अगर मैं चाहता हूं क्योंकि इसने
क्या कर दिया था कि सबको एक साथ एक्सेस
किया स्पेस सेपरेटेड कर दिया को
इंडिविजुअल वर्ड बना दिया और आपको पता
वर्ड के ऊपर व स्प्लिटिंग काम करती है अभी
मुझे क्या करना है अगर मैं चाहता हूं कि
स्क्रिप्ट में काम करे मैं तो चाहता था कि
डेली फीडबैक और मंथली रिपोर्ट एक ही फाइल
क्रिएट हो तो उसके लिए मुझे क्या करना
पड़ा वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग को होने से रोकना
होगा अगर मुझे वर्ड स्लिटिंग को रोकना है
तो उसके लिए मुझे क्या करना होगा एक बार
तो मैं इनको रिमूव कर देता हूं टूथ फोर यस
उसके बाद रिमूव मैं क्या करता हूं
डेली डेली उसके बाद फीडबैक
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं मंथली उसके
बाद रिपोर्ट्स इनको रिमूव कर दिया देन मैं
ननो करता हूं स्प के अंदर जाता हूं अब मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं आपके बार इसको कर देता
हूं डबल कोट के अंदर मैं इसको कर देता हूं
डबल कोट के अंदर अब क्या व स्प्लिटिंग काम
ही नहीं करेगी कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स
देन ये रहा व स्प्लिटिंग अब काम नहीं
करेगा तो मैं अ स्क्रिप्ट को रन करता हूं
हिट एंटर देन अभी एलस करके दिखाता हूं
आपको देखो अभी जो क्रिएट हुई होगी देखो ये
डेली फीडबैक और एक मंथली रिपोर्ट्स अब
सिर्फ दो ही फाइल क्रिएट हुई क्योंकि अभी
वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म नहीं हो रहा देखो
इस तरीके से यहां पे काम क्या है अब डॉलर
स्टार का आपको यूज करके दिखाने की मुझे
वैसे जरूरत नहीं है लेकिन मैं आपको एक
स्क्रिप्ट दिखाता हूं आपको डॉलर उस वाली
स्टार उसके अंदर तो आपको अगर समझना हो तो
मुझे एक काम करता हूं ये रहा ये रहा देन
देन देन देन ये रहा अ ये रहा ओके नैनो
कहां गया
अरे
यार ननो किया ट अब मैं क्या करता हूं य पर
पहले मैं आईएफस वेरिएबल क्योंकि वैसे तो
आईस वेरिएबल वैल्यू क्या है आपकी आपकी जो
आ वेरिएबल वैल्यू है आपकी स्पेस है तो
आपको पता चलेगा ी मैं क्या करता हूं अब
मैं क्या करता हूं डॉलर य पर कर देता हूं
स्टार य पर क्या करता हूं डॉलर स्टार डॉलर
स्टार कर देता हूं किसके अंदर इसके अंदर
और कंट्रोल एस और कंट्रोल एक्स अभी मैं
क्या करने वाला हूं अभी जो स्पेस कट हो था
अब मैं क्या कर रहा टच कर रहा हूं तो अभी
मैंने जो वैल्यू दूंगा मैं ये रही अब इसकी
जगह स्पेस एट दे रहा हूं वसे टूथ 4 और हिट
एंटर कर दिया अभी देखना एलस करके देखोगे
तो आपको जो इसने जो कन्वर्ट किया टूथ 4
कॉमा सेपरेट करया इसलिए इसने क्या इसको एक
ही फाइल क्रिएट किया क्योंकि आपको पता है
अगर मैं डॉलर एस या डॉलर स्टार यूज करूंगा
तो ये उसको क्या करता है जो आस वेरिएबल के
सबसे पहली जो वैल्यू है उस उसको उनके बीच
में रख देगा क्योंकि ये भी एक साथ सबको
एक्सेस करेगा लेकिन उनको जो इंडिविजुअल
वर्ड में क्या करेगा कन्वर्ट करेगा
इंडिविजुअल वर्ड में उसको सेपरेट करेगा तो
उसको आईएफएस वेरिएबल जो फर्स्ट वैल्यू
उसके बेस पे ही उसको सेपरेट करेगा क्योंकि
आईएस वेरिएबल वैल्यू मैंने कोमन रखे थी तो
ये था आपका स्पेशल पैरामीटर आपको डॉलर हैच
डॉलर जीरो डॉलर स्टार उसके बाद डॉलर एट द
रेट अगर दोन डबल कोट कर दे तो आपको पता चल
गया कि वड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म होगी या
नहीं होगी और इनकी वैल्यू क्या आएगी यह
आपके सामने पता चल गई होगी तो मुझे एक बार
जल्दी से चैट में बताइए कि स्पेशल
पैरामीटर आपको समझ में आया या नहीं आया
प्लीज मुझे फटाफट बताइए चैट
में गुड इवनिंग सर
बउ
पर जो स्टॉक मार्केट मुझे लगता है आपको
कुछ ज्यादा जल्दी है आप चाहते हो कि जल्दी
से जल्दी खत्म हो जाए सब कुछ बस एक दिन
में सब कुछ सीख जाए अगर आप इस तरह के सोच
के आए हो कि सर आज एक दिन में या 10 दिन
में सब कुछ हमारा खत्म करवा दे सिलेबस और
हमको मास्टर बना देता आम सॉरी फॉर दिस इ
नॉट फॉर यू मैं उन लोगों में से नहीं जो
आपको टाइम पास
करवाऊं
मैं आपको टाइम पास करने के लिए मजबूर नहीं
कर रहा क्योंकि मैं सिखाऊंगा मेरा काम
सिखाना है और मैं बिल्कुल आराम आराम से
सिखाऊंगा आपको इसलिए सिखा रहा हूं कक कुछ
स्लो भी होते हैं जिनको क्या है कि धीरे
धीरे चीज समझ में आती है आराम आराम से
समझना चाहते हैं टॉपिक वाइ टॉपिक वाइ
समझना चाहते तो उनके लिए फिर यह बेस्ट है
और आप लोगों को इसकी वैल्यू अभी नहीं पता
चलेगी अ जैसे कि रियल वर्ल्ड में जाओगे ना
जैसे ही रियल वर्ल्ड में आप खास करके
लिनेस के वर्ल्ड में जब आप हैकिंग करने भी
बैठोगे तब आपको पता चलेगा कि मैंने जो
बताया था कि कितना वैल्युएबल और कितना नॉट
वैल्युएबल है वहां पर जब ये चीजें आप
हाथों से यूज करोगे और पता चलेगा व अच्छा
अच्छा अच्छा ये छोटी सी मिस्टेक मेरे को
हैकिंग करने से रोकती है तो तब आपको पता
चलेगा अभी आपको इसकी वैल्यू नहीं है और
देखो सब खाली हो गए ओके चलो हम कंटिन्यू
करते हैं फिर नेक्स्ट आप लोग लिए
असाइनमेंट है वैसे अगर आप चाहो तो जो भी
अवेलेबल है आप लोग असाइनमेंट ग्रुप में
भेज दूंगा फिर कि ताकि आप लोग उसको कर ले
तीन असाइनमेंट है उसके फिर हम डिस्कस
[संगीत]
करेंगे वैसे आप लोग के लिए अगर असाइनमेंट
शो कर देता हूं यह रहा असाइनमेंट आप लोग
इसके बेस पर जो असाइनमेंट रहेगा यह है
आपका यह असाइनमेंट है जो आप लोग को करना
है नहीं तो नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको मैं
डिस्कस करूंगा असाइनमेंट यह है कि आपने
इससे पहले एक असाइनमेंट किया था ये रहा कि
एक कोड क्रिएट किया था जहां पर कैलकुलेशन
मल्टीप्लिकेशन किया था सी टाइप का इसने
बोला है कि रिफ्लेक्टिंग बैक ऑन योर
कैलकुलेटर प्रोजेक्ट एंड हैविंग नाउ लर्न
अबाउट स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स यू रिलाइज दैट
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स वुड मेक फॉर ए मच
क्लीयर क्लीनर स्क्रिप्ट देन पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स आपको पोजीशन पैरामीटर की व
स्पेशल पैरामीटर के बारे में पता है उसी
चीज का आपको बेनिफिट उठाना है तो वन बिग
बेनिफिट इज दैट बिकॉज ऑफ देर जनरल नेचर
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स वुड अलाव यू कैलकुलेटर
टू ऑपरेट इन फाइना नंबर्स रदर देन बीइंग
लिमिटेड टू यूजिंग द नंबर्स ऑफ पैरामीटर
देन यू रेफरेंस इन द स्क्रिप्ट प पिछली
स्क्रिप में क्या कर दिया था कि हम
अनलिमिटेड नंबर्स यूज नहीं कर सकते
क्योंकि हम हमने क्या कर कि हमने 10 तक
लिमिट रखा कि हम 10 पोजीशन पैरामीटर की
वैल्यू को सबक्स एडिशन करेंगे अब य लिमिट
आपकी हट गई है बिकॉज ऑफ स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स
यू वुड आल्सो बी एबल टू प्रोवाइड मल्टीपल
डिफरेंट ऑपरेटर्स बिटवीन ईच नंबर विद दिस
सॉल्यूशन यू डिसाइड टू मॉडिफाई योर
कैलकुलेटर स्क्रिप्ट टू यूज स्पेशल
पैरामीटर्स इंस्टेड और लास्ट क्लास में
मैंने क्या किया कि कैलकुलेटर जो
स्क्रिप्ट थी असाइनमेंट था वो मैंने खुद
से आपके सामने परफॉर्म करके दिखाया था तो
अगर आपको नहीं मालूम है तो प्लीज जाइए डे
12 की क्लास में उसको देखिए कि मैंने कैसे
परफॉर्म किया था उसी को इसमें मॉडिफाई
करना है ज्यादा कुछ भी नहीं करना लेकिन
अभी क्या है आपको इसमें यूज करना है
स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स को रदर देन पोजीशन
पैरामीटर मॉडिफाई द कैलकुलेटर स्क्रिप्ट ट
वी
प्रोजेक्ट अलिर एंड रिप्लेस द पोजीशन
पैरामीटर विद स्पेशल पैरामीटर दैट विल डू
द सेम जॉब ऑन इट्स ओन बिल्कुल सेम जॉब
करेगी रिजल्टिंग स्क्रिप्ट शुड इनेबल ए
यूजर टू रन कैलकुलेशन यूजिंग एन अनलिमिटेड
नंबर्स अमाउंट ऑफ नंबर्स एंड मोर देन वन
ऑपरेटर ओके तो यह रहा
आपका असाइनमेंट तो आप चाहो तो इसको
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए देख लीजिए ध्यान से
तो आपको यह परफॉर्म करना है अगर आप यह
परफॉर्म नहीं कर पा रहे हो तो कोई बात
नहीं नेक्स्ट क्लास में मैं आपको सॉल्व
करके दिखाऊंगा आपके सामने इट्स ओके आपको
नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपके सामने शो करके
दिखाऊंगा बेसिकली आपको कैलकुलेटर
स्क्रिप्ट बनानी
है और जो ऑलरेडी जो लास्ट क्लास में मैंने
डे 12 में आपको बताई थी उसको मॉडिफाई करना
है विद द हेल्प ऑफ स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स यह
साइज कंडीशन फुलफिल करते हुए आपको उसको
डिजाइन करना है ओके तो अभी हम कंटिन्यू
करते हैं अपनी क्लास को तो नेक्स्ट जो
टॉपिक आज हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
वह है आपका
अभी रीड कमांड के बारे में रीड कमांड के
बारे में क्या होती है देखो क्या होता है
कि अभी तक मैंने पोजीशन पैरामीटर के बारे
में पता
है प पैरामीटर क्या करता था कि कमांड देते
कमांड के बाद आप कुछ ऑप्शन मेंशन करते थे
या कुछ भी इनपुट मेंशन उसके बेस स् कम
करती थी अभी क्या है कि अगर मैं चाहता हूं
देखो यूजर यूजर इंटरेक्शन तो अभी भी हो
रहा था अभी यूजर से इनपुट ले रहा था लेकिन
मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि मे स्क्रिप्ट थोड़ी
सी और इंटरेक्ट हो यूजर के साथ थोड़ा
इंटरेक्शन करे उसको समझ में आए एक्चुअल
में की जो मेरा जो स्क्रिप्ट बनाई गई है
मुझे उसमें क्या परफॉर्म करना है मुझे
क्या इनपुट देना है तो मैं बेसिकली मेरा
अगर मोटो क्या है कि मैं अगर यूजर से
इनपुट चाहता हूं वो भी इंटरेक्ट वली
सिमिलर परपज है लेकिन क्या है इंटरेक्ट
वली चाहता हूं थोड़ा इंटरेक्ट कर पाऊ यूजर
से यूजर समझ पाए कि वो क्या चीज सेलेक्ट
कर रहा है या क्या चीज वो इनपुट दे रहा है
सोच समझ पा सोच समझ क्योंकि स्क्रिप्ट
बनाई है उसको समझ में भी तो आनी चाहिए ना
तो अगर मैं यूजर से इनपुट लेना चाह उसके
लिए मैं यूज करता हूं रीड कमांड रीड कमांड
क्या करती है कि जो भी इनपुट यूजर्स को
देता है उसको एक वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर कर
लेती है और जो बाय डिफॉल्ट वेरिएबल है
उसको बोलते हैं हम रिप्लाई उसको बोलते हैं
हम रिप्लाई वेरिएबल के अंदर उसकी वैल्यू
स्टोर कर लेती है उसके बाद उस स्टोर करने
उसको हम क्या अपने स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कहीं
भी यूज कर सकते हैं अपने रेफरेंस के लिए
उस वैल्यू को यूज करने के लिए वेरिएबल कौन
सा होता है मैं जब एकको करता हूं डॉलर
रिप्लाई आरई पी एल वाई रिप्लाई हिट एंटर
अब ये खाली है क्योंकि अभी तक मैंने रीड
कमांड का यूज नहीं किया है जब रीड कमांड
की हेल्प से जब कोई भी इनपुट हम देंगे तो
बाय डिफॉल्ट इस वेरिएबल के अंदर उसकी
वैल्यू स्टोर हो जाती है बाय डिफॉल्ट इस
वेरिएबल के अंदर उसकी वैल्यू स्टोर हो
जाती है जिसको हम फर्द स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर
कहीं पर भी यूज कर सकते हैं अब मैं क्या
करता हूं मैंने यहां पर अ डायरेक्टली मैं
रीड करके दिखाता हूं हिट एंटर कर दिया
मैंने जैसे ही मैंने रीड कमांड का यहां पे
यूज किया उसके बाद इसने क्या कर दिया
टर्मिनल पोज कर दिया ये बोल रहा कि मुझे
इनपुट दो मुझे इनपुट दो ओके मैंने इनपुट
में लिखा सचिन इनपुट में मैंने लिखा सचिन
उसके बाद स्पेस स्पेस भी कर सकते है ट
एंटर कर दिया जैसे ही मैंने हिट एंटर कर
दिया इसने इसकी वैल्यू को रिप्लाई वेरिएबल
के अंदर स्टोर कर दिया देखो रिप्लाई
वेरिएबल के अंदर इसकी क्या वैल्यू आ गई
सचिन आ गई अभी मैं क्या कर पा रहा हूं
एंटर करने पर मैं क्या दूसरी वैल्यू नहीं
ले पा रहा हूं एंटर करने पर मैं इसकी
दूसरी वैल्यू नहीं ले पा रहा हूं तो इसने
क्या है मेरे को लिमिट कर दिया कि अब आप
लोग चाहते हो क्या सर आप लोग मन में अगर
डाउट हो ग सर क्या कि क्या
मैं एक ही वैल्यू स्टोर कर सकता हूं इसकी
हेल्प से जो रीड कमांड है उसकी हेल्प से
जो रिप्लाई वेरिएबल है इसके अंदर एक ही
वैल्यू स्टोर कर सकता हूं क्या होगा अगर
मुझे क्या मल्टीपल वैल्यू स्टोर करनी हो
मल्टीपल वेरिएबल के अंदर उसका वो भी
सोल्यूशन है इसमें क्या है कि रीड कमांड
के अंदर आप क्या करते कस्टम वेरिएबल भी
डिफाइन कर सकते
कस्टम वेरिएबल भी आप डिफाइन कर सकते हो
कैसे फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या लिखा रीड
इनपुट इनपुट वन और इनपुट टू ये स्पेस ए
हिट एंटर कर दिया तो यहां पे लिखा मैंने
सचिन उसके बाद मैंने लिखा फोनिक्स और इट
एंटर कर दिया तभी जो वैल्यू देखोगी इन दो
वेरिएबल के अ अगर स्पेस सेपरेटेड वैल्यू
दी है तो इसका मतलब क्या है ये दो वेरिएबल
दो वेरिएबल के अंदर इसकी वैल्यू स्टोर हुई
है क्योंकि मैंने जो कस्टम वेरिएबल डिफाइन
किए है और दो वेरिएबल डिफाइन किए है तो
अगर मैं एकको करता हूं यहां पर एकको और
डॉलर इनपुट मैं क्या करता हूं डॉलर इनपुट
वन करता हूं ट एंटर देखो इसके अंदर सचिन
है अगर इनपुट टू करता हूं तो इसके अंदर जो
वैल्यू देखने मिर डेनिक्स देखने को मिल
रही है तो प्रैक्टिकली इसको हम अपने
स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर कैसे यूज करते हैं आपको
दिखाता हूं प्रैक्टिकली कैसे करोगे फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं एक स्क्रिप्ट कट कर रहा
हूं ननो उसके बाद स्पेशल की जगह मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं अभी स्पेशल की जगह मैं
स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करने वाला हूं एक रीड
एसए क रीड कमांड है ना मेरी तो
रीड कमांड ड एस ड कमांड ए अब मैं क्या
करता हूं य स्लश बिन उसके बाद क्या बैंग
लाइन है स्ल बिन स्स ओके उसके बाद मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं देन मैंने क्या कर दिया
रीड किया रीड उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं नेम देन स्पेस सेपरेटेड एज स्पेस
सेपरेटेड मैं लिखा नेम एज
और बर्थ बी आई आर टी एच बर्थ दिया मैंने ट
एर नहीं बर्थ नहीं चाहिए मुझे ईयर यर नहीं
तो टाउन विलेज या टाउन लिख दीजिए टान न ट
एंटर कर दिया नेक्स्ट मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं एकको उसके बाद मैंने
क्या
किया
माय नेम इज डॉलर नेम माय नेम इज डॉलर नेम
उसके बाद टर कर दिया उसके बाद एकको
किया ल कोट माय एज इज डॉलर
एज उसके बाद ट एंटर अब एक को किया मैंने
उसके बाद डबल कोट के अंदर
माय टाउन टाउन इज डॉलर टाउन ओ डब् एंड ट
ये हो गया अब इसके बाद मैं इसको क्या करता
हूं अब ये क्या स्पेस एड है सभी अलग-अलग
अपने वेरिएबल है नेम अलग वेरिएबल है ए अलग
वेरिएबल टाउन अलग वेरिएबल है कंट्रोल एस
कंट्रोल एक्स देन मैं क्या करता हूं सी
मोड उसके बाद 744 परमिशन दे देते इसको रीड
कमांड ट एंटर कर दिया नेक्स्ट करता ड
कमांड ड एस टर कर दिया अब यह बोल रहा है
कि मुझे इनपुट दीजिए मुझे इनपुट दीजिए मैं
नाम क्या लिखा सचिन
ज 27 देन मैं लिखता हूं आपको ल मैंने
लिखा टाउन लिख देता टान एनीथिंग मुंबई
लिखा
मुंबई मुंबई और य टेंटर कर दिया मैंने
क्योंकि तीन ही वेरिएबल चाहिए थे अब मुझे
तो पता देखो माय नेम इज सचिन माय एज इज 27
माय टाउन इज मुंबई ओके अब मुझे तो पता था
कि तीन वेरिएबल देने हैं बट अब मुझे यूजर
को कैसे समझाऊ कि भैया मुझे इसमें देना
क्या है ठीक है उसने स्क्रिप्ट रन किया है
ब्लैंक आ गया अब इनपुट में उसे देना क्या
है ये तो यूजर को समझाना पड़ेगा ना आपको
तो उसके लिए आप क्या है आपके पास ऑप्शंस
होते हैं रीड कमांड के साथ जो आप यूज कर
सकते हो आप प्रोमट करवा सकते हो क्योंकि
बाकी लैंग्वेज की तरह इसमें भी क्या करवा
सकते प्रम करवा सकते हो तो मैं क्या करर
हूं चलो ओके प्रम करवा सकता हूं इसको मैं
मॉडिफाई करता हूं स्क्रिप्ट को अभी मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं अभी इसको हटा देता हूं
मैं अब इसको मैं क्या करता हूं हटा देता
हूं रीड के साथ में यूज करता हूं हान प
हान यूज कर प यूज कर प्रम करवा उसके बाद
मुझे डबल कोट देना है डबल कोड जिसको मुझे
प्रोमट करवाना उसको डबल कोट के अंदर मेंशन
करूंगा
इनपुट
यवर इनपुट योर फर्स्ट नेम इनपुट योर
फर्स्ट नेम उसके बाद मैं इसको क्या कर रहा
हूं यह उसका इसको क्या थोड़ा स्पेस देता
हूं ताकि उ समझ में आए देन स्पेस के बाद
मैं यहां पर मेंशन य तो क्या आपका प्रोमट
करेगा ये आपका यूजर के लिए सामने प्रोमट
करेगा इनपुट यर फर्स्ट नेम उसके बाद ये
प्रोमट करेगा मुझे वेरिएबल के अंदर स्टोर
करवाना वेरिएबल क्या है नेम ये मेरा नेम
है तो उसके बाद य पर मेंशन करता हूं
वेरिएबल का नाम नेक्स्ट मैं इसको क्या
करता हं कॉपी कर लेता हूं एक बार कंट्रोल
सी ओके यहां पर काम कर कंट्रोल व
चलो यह काम नहीं कर रहा इसके बाद मैं क्या
करर रीड देन हाइन प प्रम करवा रहा हूं
उसके बाद मैं क्या डबल कोट उसके बाद इनपुट
योर ए देन य स्पेस उसके बाद क्या ए
वेरिएबल के अंदर नेक्स्ट उसके बाद ट एंटर
उसके बाद रीड देन हाइन प उसके बाद में
इनपुट कक जो चीज प्रम करवाना उसको डबल कोड
के अंदर लिख रहा हं
इनपुट
योर टान इनपुट योर टाउन इनपुट योर टाउन
ओके इनपुट योर टाउन य हो सकते
हो उसके बाद ये रहा इसके देन उसके बाद
टाउन फॉर एग्जांपल टाउन गिव मी वन मिनट न
होल्ड ऑन होल्ड
ऑन
सॉरी फॉर डिस्टरबेंस तो अभी क्या करता हूं
अब मैंने तीन वेरिएबल के नाम डिफाइन कर
दिए और प्रम भी कर दिया कि इनपुट यर टाउन
एंड इनपुट योर यज एंड इनपुट योर फर्स्ट
नेम अभी उसके बाद क्या ये आपका जो य पर
मेंशन किया य सब वेरिएबल के नाम है स्पे
देन कंट्रोल कंट्रोल एक्स देन मैं क्या
करता हूं अभी स्क्रिप्ट को रन करता हूं
हिट एंटर अभी देखिए इनपुट योर फर्स्ट नेम
सिंपली अब प्रोमट कर दिया अभी क्या
बेहतरीन लग रहा उससे पहले बटर अच्छा लग इट
र ए7 देन टाउन मैंने लिखा मुंबई ओके देन
हिट एंटर अभी इसने आपके सामने आउटपुट शो
कर दिया तो यह क्या है थोड़ा सा इंटरेक्ट
लग रहा है अट्रैक्टिव लग रहा है और काफी
समझ में भी आ रहा है कि मुझे जब स्क्रिप्ट
को रन कर रहा हूं तो मुझे इसमें इनपुट में
देना क्या है क्योंकि क्लियर होना चाहिए
ना आपके यूजर को अदर वाइज क्लियर नहीं हो
हो तो उसको पता नहीं चलेगा स्क्रिप्ट क्या
चाहती है मुझसे और मुझे यहां पर इनपुट में
क्या मेंशन करना है क्या नहीं मेंशन करना
तभी तो उसके हिसाब से उसमें आउटपुट आएगा
ना तो ये था आपका इंटरेक्ट का थोड़ा सा और
इसमें क्या है और भी कुछ ऑप्शंस है जो हम
डिस्कस करने वाले हैं और क्याक ऑप्शंस है
कि फॉर एग्जांपल क्या होता है कि जैसे
मैंने स्क्रिप्ट को रन किया अब मैंने इसको
स्क्रिप्ट को रन कर दिया य इनपुट योर
फर्स्ट नेम अभी क्या है यूजर्स इसमें आपका
फर्स्ट नेम डिफाइन ही नहीं कर रहा और यहां
पर क्या कर दिया या तो उसकी सिस्टम एरर आई
या वो हैंग हो गया कुछ भी कर गया है और
स्क्रिप्ट आपकी जो स्क्रिप्ट है वो कोई
इंपोर्टेंट स्क्रिप्ट है वो आपकी जो
स्क्रिप्ट है वो काफी इंपोर्टेंट
स्क्रिप्ट है तो आप क्या चाहते हो कि चलो
ठीक है यूजर्स ने इनपुट दे ही नहीं रहा तो
यहां पर आप क्या कर टाइम टाइम स्पेंड
बाउंड करना चाहते हो टाइम स्प देना चाहते
हो कि हां इतनी सेकंड तक वेट करें अगर
इनपुट देता नहीं है तो उसके बाद क्या
नेक्स्ट ऑप्शन प ऑटोमेटिक चले जाए मेरी
स्क्रिप्ट रुकनी नहीं चाहिए मेरी
स्क्रिप्ट इंपोर्टेंट है भैया हम
स्क्रिप्ट खनी नहीं चाहिए बाय डिफॉल्ट मैं
बिहाइंड द सीन क्या कर उसकी वैल्यू फिक्स
करके रखूंगा अगर यूजर को वैल्यू नहीं देता
है तो मैं क्या करूंगा उस वैल्यू को
ऑटोमेटिक रख दूंगा बट क्या है कि अभी यूजर
के लिए इतना वेट नहीं करूंगा तो यहां पर
क्या कर सकते हो आप टाइम स्पेंड मेंशन
टाइम स्टैंप है ना वो मेंशन कर सकते हो
कंट्रोल कंट्रोल सी कर देता हूं इधर देन
उसके बाद वो कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं हम ड
कमांड के साथ ये रहा ये रहा अब यहां पर
क्या करोगे हान p है तो इससे पहले आप क्या
करोगे स्पेस हाइन t टाइम स्पेंड मेंशन
करोगे उसके बाद यहां पर लिख दिया मैंने फ
सेकंड उसके बाद यहां पर मैंने मेंशन कर
दिया फ सेकंड नेक्स्ट यहां पर है क्या
आईटी उसके बाद फ सेकंड देन उसके बाद मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं आ उसके बाद कर फ सेकंड य
रहा अभी क्या पा सेकंड वेट करे पा सेकंड
से ज्यादा वेट नहीं करेगा कोई यूजर आप
इनपुट नहीं देता है तो य क्या आगे बढ़
जाएगा कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स देन अब मैं
फिर से स्क्रिप्ट को रन करता य रहा अ इसने
क्या कर फ पा सेकंड तक वेट करते काम कर भी
रहा है या नहीं कर रहा टा देखो इनपुट योर
एज देन नेक्स्ट अभय पा सेकंड के बाद इनपुट
र
अभी भी कुछ भी किसी ने कुछ मेंशन नहीं
किया तो क्या आपकी स्क्रिप्ट को रन करेगा
या आपके लिए पोज नहीं करेगा अभी उसने सब
कुछ खाली करके दिखा दिया बट क्या अजीब सा
दिख रहा है कि बोलाय अट्रैक्टिव लुकिंग ये
तो हम कर सकते हैं बीच में एक को कमांड
देंगे तो क्या न्यू लाइन का काम करेगा तो
इस तरीके से आप यह भी कर सकते हो दूसरा और
क्या कर सकते हो रीड कमांड के साथ और क्या
क्या ऑप्शन कर यूज कर सकते हो फॉर
एग्जांपल यह रहा आपकी रीड कमांड अभी मैं
क्या चाहता हूं य तो मैंने यूज कर लिया t5
t4 उसके बाद और भी ऑप्शन होते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं अभी और थोड़ा अट्रैक्टिव
बनाते इसको इसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया
को मेंशन कर दिया ताकि थोड़ा अच्छा दिखे
दिया देन नू लाइन में एक लाइन में ना उसके
बाद
को और यहां पर क्या कर रहा हूं की य पर
लिखा इनपुट यर यूजर नेम कोई भी इनपुट यर
यूजर नेम इनपुट र यूजर नेम य पर मेंशन कर
रहा
हूं
योर कोड एंड इनपुट यर पासवर्ड इनपुट योर
पासवर्ड पासवर्ड अब अब इसमें ठीक है कोड
और ये पासवर्ड है दोनों क्या है कि आप
चाहते हो कि स्क्रीन प दिखे ना पुट यो
पासवर्ड ये क्या है स्क्रीन पे आपको दिखे
ना तो उसके लिए आप क्या कर सकते हो ठीक है
ये भी चलेगा नेक्स्ट मैं क्या करता हूं
हाइन एक एस होता है सीक्रेट हाइन एस जब भी
आप पासवर्ड मेंस कई बार आपके स्क्रिप्ट के
अंदर तो आपको पासवर्ड की जगह डॉट डॉट
दिखाई देता खाली स्पेस दिखाई देता है तो
पासवर्ड दिखाई देता था ये वो ऑप्शन है रीड
हान s किया तो ये सीक्रेट ऑप्शन है तो
कंट्रोल एस और कंट्रोल एक्स देन अब मैं
इसको क्या करता हूं ड एस करता हूं तो देखो
ठीक है इनपुट योर नेम मैंने लिख दिया अभी
अभी लिख दिया मैंने नाम लिख रहा हं जती
ओके इनपुट यर कोड 6789 आपको दिखाई नहीं दे
रहा ट एंटर कर दिया पासवर्ड कुछ भी दे
दिया मैंने यह रहा ट एटर अभी देखो जो जो
मैंने मेंशन कर दिया था व आपको देखने को
माय नेम इ ये माय एज ये माय व्ट एवर जो भी
मैंने मेंशन करना था अब य पर माय नेम खाली
क्यों आया क्योंकि सेकंड से आगे बढ़ गया
था तो यह था आपको समझ में आ गया होगा कि
कैसे काम कर आपके स्किप य आपका जो रीड
कमांड थी ड कमांड इस तरीके से काम करती है
इसके बेसिस में भी एक इंपोर्टेंट क्या है
आपका असाइनमेंट है तो मैं चाहू तो आपको
दिखा देता हूं आपको क्या परफॉर्म करना है
या उसको हम क्या करते परम खुद से ही कर
देते हैं उसको चाहो तो हम उसको अभी कर
सकते असाइनमेंट को असाइनमेंट एक काम करते
हैं असाइनमेंट टू असाइनमेंट थ्री
असाइनमेंट फोर हम कल करते हैं आज एक और
टॉपिक खत्म कर लेते हैं रीड कमांड के बाद
हम एक और नेक्स्ट कमांड और पढ़ लेते हैं
जो आपकी है सेलेक्ट कमांड आपकी जो है
सेलेक्ट कमांड के बारे में पढ़ लेते हैं
तो ये आपकी रीड कमांड थी रीड कमांड को इस
तरीके से आप यूज कर सकते हो आपकी उसके
अंदर स्क्रिप्ट के अंदर किसी भी स्क्रिप्ट
के अंदर काफी इंटरेक्ट बना देती है आपकी
स्क्रिप्ट को नेक्स्ट बात करते हैं हम
सेलेक्ट कमांड के बारे में नेक्स्ट बात
करते हैं किसके बारे में सेलेक्ट कमांड के
बारे में वो है आपकी सेलेक्ट कमांड एस ई
एल सी
सेलेक्ट यार आपकी कौन सी
है लेक कमांड
ओके कोई इशू है इसके साथ यार कंट्रोल सी
सेलेक्ट कमांड अब सेलेक्ट कमांड हम क्यों
यूज करते हैं रीड कमांड यूज कर रहे हैं तो
सेलेक्ट कमांड यूज क्यों करते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल कई बार आपने देखा होगा कि अगर
आपने मेटा फ्रेमवर्क यूज किया है या कुछ
और भी आपने टूल्स यूज किए होंगे जहां पर
आपको क्या ऑप्शंस देखने को मिलते हैं टूथ
या कुछ भी ऑप्शन सेलेक्ट करते हो उसके
बेसिस पर उसका कोड परफॉर्म किया जाता है
उसके बेसिस पर आपका आउटपुट परफॉर्म किया
जाता है तो उसी तरीके से अगर आप अपने
यूजर्स को मल्टीपल ऑप्शन देना चाहते हो
उसको चॉइस देना चाहते हो सिलेक्शन चॉइस कि
भैया आप एक काम करो कि इनमें से अपनी चॉइस
लो जो आप चाहते हो और उसके बेसिस पर आपको
आपका आउटपुट देखने को मिलेगा अगर उस तरीके
का आप काम करना चाहते हो तो उसके लिए आपको
यूज करना पड़ेगा सेलेक्ट कमांड का कैसे फर
एपल मैं नो करता हूं उसके बाद
सेलेक्ट उसके बाद डॉट एस सेलेक्ट डॉट एस
उसके बाद मैं मेंशन करता हूं मार्क स बैंग
लाइन और बिन और बेस बिन और बिन और ये बेस
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा उसके बाद ये
रहा अब सेलेक्ट कमांड को यूज कैसे करते
हैं बताता हूं सबसे पहले आप मेंशन करोगे ए
सेलेक्ट यहां पर लिखोगे सेलेक्ट देन यहां
पर आप मेंशन करोगे वेरिएबल का नाम कोई भी
वेरिएबल नाम मेंशन करो मैं यहां पर लिख
रहा हूं डे मेरा वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद
इन इन यहां पर कंपलसरी है रिजर्व्ड है
मतलब अब इन का मतलब इसके आगे जितने भी मैं
मेंशन करूंगा स्पेस सेपरेट वो सारे के
सारे क्या होंगे ऑप्शंस होंगे मंडे
ट्यूजडे वेडनेसडे
थर्सडे उसके बाद फ्राइडे और सैटरडे ये
सारे सारे क्या स्पेस टेड ऑप्शंस है
सिलेक्ट लिखूंगा देन वेरिएबल का नाम देन
उसके बाद इन इन का मतलब मुझे इनके बाद जो
भी लिख रहा हूं वो सारे ऑप्शंस है इनमें
से मुझे क्या करना है इस वेरिएबल के अंदर
उस वैल्यू को रखना है और ये सारे ऑप्शंस
क्या आपके यूजर्स को देखने को मिलेंगे
जैसे डीडी में दिखते ऐसे ये इन से यूजर
आपका सेलेक्ट कर सकता है उसके बाद जब तक
स्पेस ए और जैसे ही आपने सेमीकलन मेंशन कर
दिया आपके जो कमांड है वो समझ जाएगा या
आपका जो टर्मिनल आपका सेल समझ जाएगा बैस
समझ जाएगा कि हां यहां मेरे ऑप्शन एंड हो
गई इतने ही ऑप्शन मैंने आपके किसके सामने
शो करने है यूजर के सामने उसके बाद एंटर
किया नेक्स्ट लाइन यहां पर डू लिखूंगा अी
जो आप लॉजिक या जो टास्क परफॉर्म करना
चाहते हो ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ या जो भी कोड आप
परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो किसके बेसिस पर इन
ऑप्शंस के बेसिस पे उसके बाद डू के बाद
आपको वो कोड लिखोगे जो कोड आप परफॉर्म
करना चाहते हो फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने लिखा
एकको नेक्स्ट मैंने लिखा उसके बाद लिखा ये
रहा उसके बाद
द डे ऑ ऑफ द
वीक ऑ द वीक इज उसके बाद मैं लिखा डॉलर और
डे डॉलर
डे उसके बाद ये डे ऑफ द वीक डॉलर
डे उसके बाद यह मैंने कोड लिखा था उसके
बाद मैंने अब क्या कर दिया अभी क्या है
किय कंपाउंड कमांड है कंपाउंड कमांड
रिजर्व से स्टार्ट होती है रिजर्व वर्ड से
खत्म होती है डू और रिजर्व वर्ड से डू और
डन अब डन से क्या हो खत्म इसने मैं आपको
सेलेक्ट लिखना है वेरिएबल का नाम इन उसके
बाद ऑप्शन जो जो आप मेंशन करते हो स्पेस
सेपरेटेड उसके बाद जो उनके उसके ऊपर आप
टास्क परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो वो डू और डन
के बीच में आप टास्क परफॉर्म करोगे यहां
पर वो टास्क परफॉर्म किया जाएगा जो कोड
परफॉर्म करना है डू के बाद और डन से पहले
उसके बाद इसको क्लोज करने के लिए आप यूज
करोगे डन अब इसको कंट्रोल एस कर देता हूं
कंट्रोल एक्स अब आपके स्क्रिप्ट को मैं
सीच मोड देन मा से और फो उसके बाद आपने
सेलेक्ट अभी आपको समझ में रहा कि जो बैस
की जो कमांड है जितने भी आप कमांड यूज
करते हो आपके स्क्रीन के ऊपर उसमें जो
ऑप्शन कई बार आपको देखने मिते है खास करके
बेस वाली में तो सिलेक्शन कैसे होता है इस
तरीके से ही वो कमांड काम करती है जिस
तरीके से आप देख रहे हो इसी तरीके से
छोटी-छोटी चीजों को जोड़ जोड़ के मिक्स
करके हम कोड को डिजाइन करते हैं एक
बेहतरीन टूल बना लेते हैं अब उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता हूं इसको रन कर देता हूं अब
इसको सेलेक्ट डॉट एएच देखो अब आपके सामने
ऑप्शंस आ गए कि मंडे ट्यूसडे वेडनेसडे
थर्सडे फ्राइडे मुझे कौन सा चूज करना है
सिक्स है मैंने अगर चूज किया टू इट एंटर
अभी देखो द डे ऑफ द वीक इज ट्यूजडे अब
मैंने अब फिर से क्या लूप में चल पड़ा
देखो इसकी खासियत क्या है स्लेक कमांड की
कि जब तक इसको आप या तो कंट्रोल सी से
ब्रेक नहीं करोगे या एक और जो तरीका मैं
आपको बताऊंगा तब तक य क्या लूप में चलता
है मैंने सिक्स सिलेक्शन कर दिया हिट एंटर
ये फिर से लूप में चला गया वन लिखा हिट
एंटर उसके बाद फिर से फोर लिखा ये रहा डे
ऑफ द वीक इज थर्सडे उसके बाद अगर मैंने
फिर से सिक्स लिख दिया डे ऑफ द वीक ये ये
लूप में चलता रहेगा लेकिन इस तरीके से
आपने ऑप्शंस खासकर मेटा स्लट फ्रेमवर्क हो
गया और अदर फ्रेमवर्क वहां पर आपको देखने
को मिलते हैं उसके बाद एक जस्ट नंबर मेंशन
करते हो और उसके बाद क्या हो सिलेक्शन हो
जाता है तो अभी यहां पर दो तरीके इसको
क्लोज करने के लिए तो कंट्रोल सी यूज
करोगे कंट्रोल सी कर दे कमांड से आउट हो
गए दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या है इसको दस दूसरा
ऑप्शन आपके पास है ये रहा सेक्ट ड एच आपको
यहां क्या करना होगा जैसे ही जो भी ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट कर लोगे उसके बाद जैसे उसका टास्क
परफॉम उसके बाद क्या कर दो आप ब्रेक लिख
दो क्या करो स्टॉप कर दो इसको मुझे नहीं
चाहिए लूपिंग नहीं चाहिए कंट्रोल एस
कंट्रोल एक्स अब मैं इसको लिखता हूं देखो
एस अभी ऑप्शन एक सेलेक्ट करो आपने ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट किया थ्री ट एंटर देखो डे ऑफ द
वीक इ विटनेस डे देन आपके स्क्रिप्ट
एग्जिट होगी मतलब वहां से ब्रेक कर
दिया चलो एक तो यह था अभी आपको देखने को
मिल रहा होगा कि अब यह सारी चीज आ कहां से
रही है कैसे परफॉर्म हो रही है ब्रेक करने
का तरीका मैंने आपको बता दिया तो देखो हो
क्या रहा है कि आपके जो लिनक्स है नाना
तो बेसिकली जो स्लैक कमांड में जितने भी
आप ऑप्शंस मेंशन करते हो और वो जो ऑप्शंस
है जो सेलेक्ट किए जाते हैं यूजर्स के
द्वारा जो कंट्रोल किए जाते हैं वो सारा
कंट्रोल पी ए3 वेरिएबल के द्वारा ही किया
जाता है जो यूजर डिफाइंड वेरिएबल है और ये
स्पेशली किसके लिए बनाया गया है स्लेक्ट
कमांड के लिए रिजर्व है और किसी परपज से
इसको यूज किया ही नहीं जाता ओनली स्लेक्ट
कमांड के लिए परपज से इसको यूज किया जाता
है तो यह था इसका सेलेक्ट कमांड का अगर आप
चाहो तो एक और काम कर सकते हो अगर आपको
अगर और भी अट्रैक्टिव बनानी है आपके
स्क्रिप्ट को कैसे वो भी आपने देखा होगा
मैं नड ए करता हूं यहा अभी मैं क्या करता
हूं य पर चलो य मैंने य पर लिख दिया अब
सेलेक कमांड से पहले क्या करता मैं लिखता
हूं पी एस3 वेरिएबल इक्वल साइन दिया उसके
डबल कोड दे दिया मैंने हमने लिखा ट अब
यूजर को फिर भी क्या थोड़ा सा क्टी देना
आपने ऑप्शन मेंशन कर दिया लेकिन क्या
थोड़ा सा उस कंफ्यूज हो तो जैसे मैं लिखा
कि आपको देना क्या है व्ट इज
द डे ऑफ द वीक डे ऑफ द वीक उसको मेंशन
करना है क्वेश्चन मार्क देन उसके बाद ये
स्पेस सेपरेटेड उसको ऐसे सिलेक्शन करना है
उसको ऐसे सिलेक्शन करना है और उसके बाद
मैं क्या कर
कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल एक्स अब उसके बाद मैं
क्या करता
हूं ये रहा अभ ये बोल रहा है देखो पहले तो
ये आ रहा था क्योंकि पीए के वेरिएबल अंदर
था अब पीए व के वेरिएबल वैल्यू क्या है ये
रही व्हाट इज द डे ऑफ द वीक अब मुझे यहां
पर सिलेक्शन करना है तो मैंने सिक्स लिखा
ये रहा सिक्स और रिट एंटर कर दिया तभी डे
ऑफ द वीक इज द सैटरडे तो ये थोड़ा सा और
भी अट्रैक्टिव काफी गुड लुकिंग दे रहा है
अब क्या है कि हर एक ऑप्शंस के बेसिस प आप
लॉजिक लगा सकते हो हर एक ऑप्शंस के बेस पे
हम क्या कर सकते हैं लॉजिक लगा सकते हैं
और जिस ऑप्शन को सेलेक्ट किया जाएगा उसी
ऑप्शन का टास्क परफॉर्म किया जाए लॉजिक या
लूप्स लगा के इसके अंदर आप डू और डन के भी
अंदर सारा काम कर सकते हो अगर आप कोई भी
टूल डिजाइन करोगे या कोई भी अपने टास्क
ऑटोमेट टास्क परफॉर्म करना चाहते हो तो आप
इस तरीके से सेलेक्ट कमांड की हेल्प से या
रीड कमांड की हेल्प से आप और भी बेहतरीन
तरीके से क्या चीजों को डिजाइन और परफॉर्म
कर सकते हो यह था आपका सेलेक्ट कमांड और
अभी हमारे सामने तीन असाइनमेंट बचे हैं एक
असाइनमेंट आपको मैंने करने के लिए दिया है
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा क्या परफॉर्म
करना है और दूसरा असाइनमेंट और तीसरा
असाइनमेंट हम क्या करेंगे नेक्स्ट क्लास
में सबसे पहले हम असाइनमेंट परफॉर्म
करेंगे किसके बेसिस
पर रीड कमांड के बेसिस पर स्लक कमांड के
बेसिस पर और और अगर हो सके तो छोटा सा
रिवीजन कर लेंगे देन फर्द हमारा नया टॉपिक
अब हम एंटर कर ले हैं लॉजिक सेक्शन के
अंदर यह आपका क्या था अगर मैं सेक्शन की
बात करूं तो जो सेक्शन था आपका कि जो यूजर
से हमें इनपुट कैसे लेना है यह वो सेक्शन
था अगर रिक्वेस्ट हम इनपुट कैसे करना है
यूजर से या तो पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स हो या
आपके स्पेशल पैरामीटर्स हो या रीड कमांड
हो स्लक कमांड हो ये सेक्शन था एक कंप्लीट
हो गया नेक्स्ट सेक्शन आपका लॉजिस में हम
आ जाएंगे इफ कमांड वाले सेक्शन में देन
धीरे धीरे हम लूप में जाएंगे और धीरे धीरे
हम क्या है बेस जो कोर्स है ये एंडिंग पर
पहुंचेगा उसके बाद हम प्रोजेक्ट करेंगे
उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे प्रोजेक्ट्स
करेंगे
तो प्लीज ये काम कीजिए आप लोगों को कोई भी
डाउट हो तो आप मुझसे काम कर सकते हैं
नेक्स्ट दो मिनट के अंदर पूछ सकते हैं अदर
वाइज हम सेशन को क्या करेंगे एंड करने
वाले हैं उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे सेशन को
एंड करेंगे आज का टॉपिक हमारा इतना ही था
कल हम क्या असाइन मेंट के ऊपर क्या है वो
करेंगे ऑन द बेसिस ऑफ असाइनमेंट हम क्या
करने वाले हैं काम करने वाले हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में डे 14 में तीन असाइनमेंट को
डिस्कस करेंगे उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट रन
करेंगे उसके बाद फर्द अपना टॉपिक हम करने
वाले
हैं तो बताइए स्टिल हैव एनी
डाउट
ब
च लास्ट पार्ट सेलेक्ट कमांड बताइए
सेलेक्ट कमांड के बारे में
क्या बता सेलेक्ट क के बारे में मेहता
जी बताइए आर यू टॉकिंग अबाउट या आस्किंग
अबाउट स्लक
कमांड यस ओके देखो सिलेक्ट कमांड का आपको
पर्पस पता चला कि अगर आपको यूजर्स को
ऑप्शन मेंशन करने हैं तो आपको सेलेक्ट
कमांड का यूज करना होगा होगा तो सेलेक्ट
कमांड को यूज करना कैसे है कि सबसे पहले
आपको सेलेक्ट लिखना है उसके बाद वेरिएबल
का नाम मेंशन करना है उसके बाद इन ये
रिजर्व कीवर्ड है आपको कंपल्सरी मेंशन
करना है उसके बाद आप मेंशन करोगे ऑप्शंस
जो ऑप्शंस आप सिलेक्शन के लिए यूजर को
देना चाहते हो मेरा ऑप्शन है एमन फर स्पेस
एड एक ऑप्शन से दूसरे ऑप्शन के बीच में
अगर स्पेस दे रहे इसका मतलब वो दूसरा
ऑप्शन हो जाता है कंटिन्यू दोगे तो वो वन
ही ऑप्शन रहेगा तो मंडे उसके बाद ट्यूसडे
वेडनेसडे थर्सडे फ्राइडे सैटरडे ये क्या
है स्पेस एट इसके मतलब थ्री सिक्स ऑप्शन
यहां पर कर दिए जब आपके ऑप्शंस खत्म हो
जाए तो आप क्या कर सकते हो सेमीकलन यूज कर
सकते हो इसका मतलब क्या कि अभी मैं ऑप्शंस
मेरे इतने ही ऑप्शन में यूजर को शो करना
चाहता हूं या इतनी ऑप्शन यूजर को देना
चाहता हूं तो सेमीकलन से इसको एंड कर दो
नेक्स्ट आपको मेंशन करना पड़ डू अब क्या
करना कि आपने सिलेक्शन तो दे रहे हो कि
हां वेरिएबल के अंदर ये
वेरिएबल की वैल्यू आ जाएगी तो उसके बाद
क्या इसके बेस प मुझे कुछ टाक तो परफॉर्म
करना होगा कि ओनली सिलेक्शन थोना चाहता
हूं कि यूजर को मैंने ऑप्शन जो दिए हैं कि
यूजर अपनी मर्जी से ऑप्शन सिलेक्ट करे
उसके बेसिस प उसको उसका आउटपुट देखने को
मिले तो उसके बेसिस पर आपको आउटपुट के लिए
कमांड लिखनी पड़ेगी या कोड तो लिखना
पड़ेगा टास्क परफॉर्म करवाना होगा एक्शन
करवाने होंगे वो एक्शंस आप क्या करोगे डू
के बाद वो एक्शन लिखोगे और जब वो एक्शन
कंप्लीट हो जाएंगे पर्टिकुलर फॉर एग्जांपल
आप सभी के लिए भी लिख सकते हो कोड मंडे के
लिए अलग से ट्यूसडे के लिए वेडनेसडे के
लिए छह के छह ऑप्शन के अलग कोड मेंशन कर
सकते हो लेकिन जब उसमें लॉजिक यूज करके या
कंडीशन यूज करके जो भी यूज कर सते जब आपका
एक बार लगता है कि सय लॉजिक कंडीशन एक्शन
कंप्लीट हो गया कि हां देन उसके बाद आप
चाहते हो कि अब आउट करना कि सिलेक्शन
कमांड के इन ऑप्शंस के बेसिस प मैं चाहता
हूं कि इतना ही कोड परफॉर्म होने चाहिए
उसके बाद डन लगा दिया इसका मतलब क्या है
कि अब ये जो सिलेक्शन पार्ट था कंप्लीट हो
गया अब इसके बाद जो कोड होगा वो दूसरा
होगा इसके बाद क्या होगा कोड दूसरा होगा
कोई भी कोड हो सकता है और लेकिन जो
सिलेक्शन है जो ये वैल्यू है डे वन डे डे
के के अंदर जो वैल्यू आ रही है ये क्या है
ये स्टो वैसे इसके लिए रिस्पांसिबल क्या
है उसके लिए क्या एक पीएस थ वेरिएबल होता
है इसके अंदर वो वैल्यू क्या है परफॉर्म
की जाती है उसी के बेस पर आप क्या करता है
क्योंकि देखो आपने वैल्यू सिलेक्शन कर
लिया और इसके वेरिएबल के अंदर आ गया बट
क्या है कि ये सारी वैल्यू वाला जो ऑप्शन
देने वाला काम है ये जो वैल्यू जो आपके
सामने स्क्रीन के सामने आ गई वैल्यू
सिलेक्शन वाला काम वो किसकी हेल्प से हो
रहा है पी3 वेरिएबल की हेल्प से स्लेक्ट
कमांड के लिए रिजर्व किया गया जब भी आप
स्लेक्ट कमांड यूज करोगे उसके जो ऑप्शंस
प्रोवाइड करोगे उ ऑप्शंस की वैल्यू को ये
स्टोर करके रखता है आपका पी3 वेरिएबल और
उसके कमांड के अंदर यूज कर लेते हो ओके तो
सेलेक्ट कमांड के लिए इसको क्या किया गया
है रखा गया है ओके तो अब बताइए मता समझ
में आ गया
आपको बताइए
जरा
ओके चलो फिर सेशन एंड करते हैं आज के लिए
तो थैंक यू बाय बाय टेक केयर सी य फॉर
नेक्स्ट
सेशन